JASON SILVA: What's
going on guys?
Welcome to "Shots of Awe."
Now, we're doing these
extended conversations,
these creative sessions
with some of the luminaries
who have inspired so
many of these episodes.
And you're about to see my
conversation with Erik Davis.
Erik Davis wrote
"TechGnosis," which
is a book that literally
tickles my brain,
and is a cognitively
ecstatic experience
to read that man's words.
And it's fascinating,
because it's
commentaries about technology,
myth, magic, and mysticism
in the age of information.
Actually, they put
me in his head.
I feel like I read
his observations,
and I relate to them.
And the thrill of
feeling like there's
someone else in the
world who's thinking
this way about these big
issues is astonishing.
So I hope you guys enjoyed
this extended creative session
with the brilliant Erik Davis.
So Erik Davis, it's a
thrill to be here with you.
You have inspired me to no end.
I've just got to say, first
of all, let me thank you.
Thank you for your work, for
your ideas, for your book,
"TechGnosis," which
is being reissued,
and which has blown
my mind to know end.
This book looks at technology
in a very different way
than most people
think of technology.
People use technology to extend
their capacities in the world,
to extend their
communication abilities.
But people also have an
apprehension about technology.
They're afraid of that the
robots are taking over.
You look at the
Gnostic undertone.
So why don't you, at
first, just tell me
a little bit about where
"TechGnosis" came from.
ERIK DAVIS: No, that's
a great question.
I got a sense of
what was going to be
happening with technology.
In the late '80s already, I was
studying postmodern philosophy,
and reading agnosticism,
and science fiction,
and Philip K Dick.
And then I became
a culture critic.
I wrote for "The
Village Voice," and I
wrote a lot of record
reviews, and things like that.
But I noticed on the
horizon that there
were these strange
juxtapositions of technology,
and religion technology,
and mysticism.
And they were so
peculiar, because we don't
organize the world that way.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: There's religion,
and mysticism, and magic.
There are old stuff over
there, maybe in our dreams,
maybe in our fantasies.
JASON SILVA: Yep.
ERIK DAVIS: And then we have
the technology, the world we
actually--
JASON SILVA: Ration of science.
ERIK DAVIS: Rationality,
science, progress,
leaving the shadows in the wake.
And I noticed that
that's actually not true,
and that there's all ways in
our stories, in our habits,
in the images of the way that
technologies are packaged
and sold where we actually draw
from the religious imagination,
let's call it, whether it's
from Christian ideas of progress
or occult ideas of
magic spells and powers,
or Gnostic dreams
of transcendence,
and moving onward and
upward into the heavens
through our technology.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And so
what I wanted to do
is tell a secret history, an
esoteric history of technology
that paid attention and drew all
of these shadows, and figments,
and stories out
of the background
and brought them forward so
that people could see really
what was going on
already in a lot of ways.
JASON SILVA: 1,000%.
And what continuously
blows my mind,
and I experience a kind
of bibliomancy every time
I open this book.
And any page that I
open it to, there's
something really relevant
and really just astonishing
that you point out about our
relationship with technology.
One of your chapters is
called the spiritual cyborg,
that we are a cyborg.
We are in a coevolution
with our technology.
We extend our minds into our
tools, and so on, and so forth.
But that there is this
spiritual yearning,
that we are beset with a thirst
for meaning that continues.
We may build the
Hubble Space Telescope,
put that in space,
mainline space and time
through the optic nerve.
But because why?
Because we're looking
for the holy other.
We're trying to
blast new tunnels
between the mind and the other.
It always comes
back to the pressure
of being a conscious being, to
be sentient, to face mortality,
to fancy ourselves
as gods, but to be
ultimately food for worms.
And I just felt that you
just identified that thread
throughout.
And you did it so vividly.
And your power with
language, with words--
where do you go when
you write this stuff?
And also, these observations
that you were making probably
reflect a journey
that you were taking,
and it probably comes from
a place of you wanting
to understand, and
you being beset
with a thirst for meaning.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: So
tell me about that.
ERIK DAVIS: Well,
like a lot of people,
I would say I was a
spiritual seeker of sorts.
And for me, it was often a
very intellectual pursuit
where I wanted to know where
these things were coming from,
religions, and
mystery, and magic,
and the occult, and
meditation, and all that stuff.
But I was also a practitioner.
I was searching.
And in some sense, I still am.
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: So I was
fired up by that.
But at the same time, I
saw technology coming.
I understood it really well.
It was like my
father's a scientist.
I was really tuned into
science and mathematics.
I studied mathematics.
And even though I didn't
end up studying science--
I got seduced by
the humanities--
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: --I've always
had a real attraction to it,
unlike a lot of people who
work in the humanities.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: So I started to see
that all this stuff was coming.
And then it was really
going to change everything.
It was already
changing everything.
It was changing finance.
It was changing our self image.
It was changing how we
think about ourselves.
And so I could see this almost
apocalypse on the horizon.
And it was the
early '90s, and you
could tell the end of
the century's coming.
What's going to happen?
There's this sense
of a millennialism
that I was tuning into that
brought these worlds together.
So for me, it was
really an attempt
to integrate different
sides of myself,
and to continue
to tune into what
was happening in the
future, but to recognize
that these yearnings
aren't going to go away.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: They
just get rephrased
in a new point of view.
JASON SILVA: Repackaged.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
So this spiritual cyborg
is basically the idea
that a lot of people who
yearn for spirituality
or for a religious
connection, they
might think that technology is
taking us away from everything.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: That we need
to return to our roots,
return to nature.
We're too artificial,
et cetera, et cetera.
I have a lot of
appreciation for that view.
But in a way, it's obvious.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: And I wanted to
ask a deeper question which
is, what happens when
you actually embrace
the technological framework?
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: Including the idea
that we are DNA meat machines?
JASON SILVA: We're
made of language, bro.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: It's software.
ERIK DAVIS: Spinning ourselves
in the void, and now,
as we've extruded all
of these algorithms
and technological processes
that have a life of their own,
that we're now
riding this thing,
how do we engage all that
and embrace that, but still
pay attention to, even be driven
by these deeper yearnings that
go much, much farther
back in our past?
And so that's the dialectic
or tension that I'm really
trying to work out in the book.
JASON SILVA: Which is dazzling.
And you talk a lot about
the emergence of the cyber
culture in the late '90s and the
connection with the millennium,
and this idea there
was this dream,
that these tools we're
going to liberate us
from the biological
meat machine,
the biological straitjacket, and
that we were going to unleash
our minds into a virtual world.
As Terence McKenna said
about virtual reality,
this will allow us to
turn our minds inside out,
that new forms of
intersubjectivity
could be attained, because
we would graduate from being
naked monkeys making
little monkey noises,
thinking they see
God, and actually
actualize a cosmos
for the imagination
that we could inhabit.
Technology, as McKenna used to
say, is congealed imagination.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: But now,
we could actually
move into and live inside of
our congealed imagination.
We're already doing it.
Talk about architecture.
Talk about air crafts.
But even more so, the promise
of virtual reality, this
was there in that cyber
culture in the '90s,
and you were pointing to it.
But then there's been
this disenchantment now.
Do you think it's
going to come back?
Now, virtual
reality is emerging.
Now, I can rub the magic
mirror on my iPhone
and summon a car that
synchronizes with my Spotify
playlist to play the
music that I love
so that my phenomenological
flow starts to feel
like a reenchanted world.
The internet of things,
predictive, contextual
computing, starts to create
a world of enchanted objects,
a world of animism.
So all of us start
to feel like we're
in an altered state
of consciousness
where everything
is in sync with us,
and we start experiencing
engineered serendipities.
Do you think that
that's possible?
Or are you feeling like
it's a bunch of corporations
are manipulating us?
ERIK DAVIS: Well,
one of the things
that I talk about in
technosis is that when
new information technologies
enter into a culture, when
you have the telegraph, when
you have the telephone, when you
have television, radio, when
those technologies initially
enter into social reality
and begin to transform
the way that we experience
ourselves, communication,
and a relationship
to time and space.
When those things
happen, there's
a weird gap in the world
where suddenly, there's
a recognition that we're
making this up as we go along,
and it's not really clear
what the new form is.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: So into that gap
rush fantasies, and dreams,
and revelations, and terrors,
and demons, and fears.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: And
that that tension
between the up and the down,
the demon and the angel,
is part of the
inheritance of technology.
So when you asked that
question, the answer, in a way,
is boring.
It's both and, and that the
moment of revelation that we're
moving into in that
sense of oh my god,
it's all things coming together.
There's a kind of
fantasy that I'm
living through the technology.
There's a synchronicity,
these effects
that are producing a much
more enchanted sense of moving
through ordinary life--
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: --are intimately and
absolutely coupled with a deep
suspicion and alienation--
JASON SILVA: Uh-huh.
ERIK DAVIS: --and that those
are also features of technology.
They're features of
advanced capitalism,
and that if anything,
they're closer.
They rub up against
each other even more--
JASON SILVA: Than ever before.
ERIK DAVIS: Than ever before.
And so I know I'm
neither an optimistic
nor a pessimist in
the way that people
like to align themselves.
I'm much more
interested in trying
to see how the dance
between these poles happens,
and then always paying
attention to I have to own,
we have to own our
own projections too.
We have to recognize, what
are we really fearing?
What are we really
trying to transcend?
What do we really want?
You talk about Becker a lot.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: How much
is our fear of death,
our secret, constant,
unconscious awareness
that we are mortal
creatures motivating
our trivial perceptions,
our desires, our enjoyments?
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: And so
for me, it's really
about using historical
complexity, conflict,
this weird conjunction of
beauty, and awe, and terror,
and paranoia, as
this opportunity
to go even deeper into this
ever evolving human condition
and to keep that edge sharp?
JASON SILVA: Well,
it's funny you
mentioned Becker and the
idea of human mortality.
But ultimately, technology
is the ultimate antientropic
extension of biology.
Bucky Fuller used to say,
life is antientropic.
So entropy moves towards
destruction and simplification
of everything, but
then life moves
towards greater complexity
and organization-- upwillings
of structure, self-organizing,
sublime complexity that
just seems to emerge.
And then we extend our
biology with the technosphere.
Kevin Kelly calls
it the technium.
He says it's an organism,
the seventh kingdom of life.
And so that this moves
towards this antientropic move
towards more
complexity, of course
is connected to
our desire to want
to overcome entropy itself,
to overcome mortality itself.
On the one hand, you can listen
to a beautiful piece of music
while listening to your
Boise wireless headphones,
and the magical
music is streaming
from your magical
smartphone which
has 10,000 melodies
magically stored
in its electronic circuitry.
And you listen to it, and that
gives you a real experience.
There's nothing virtual
about virtual reality.
That's a real virtual
reality, as [INAUDIBLE] says.
And I listen to that music,
and I might get moved to tears.
And I'll get the
goosebumps, and the chills,
and I feel connected to
something larger than myself.
I technologically mediate
ecstasy and become as a god
almost.
I enter god mode, to
use a video game term.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: But that the
next day, I have a headache,
or I see a person
who's older and is
suffering from an illness.
And I'm like, holy shit.
This is the existential bummer.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: Should
we not use these tools
to transcend our mortal coil?
Should we not--
the ape that wants
to molt himself into angel.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: That's your line.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: We must
become machines.
We must become gods.
Man is a bridge, but not an end.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: What do
you think about that?
ERIK DAVIS: Well, I'm going
to approach it from a slightly
different angle.
JASON SILVA: OK.
ERIK DAVIS: And we'll
get to that point, which
is I have a whole riff that I'm
pretty convinced about which
is that hedonism, the
pursuit of pleasure including
awe and wonder, is
it a profound path?
In most ways of
looking at it, hedonism
is seen as superficial,
materialistic.
It's not religious.
It's unethical.
It's not higher.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And our society
and ourselves are very hedonic.
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: We are trained,
and we are learned to enjoy,
and we have great pleasures
that are at our fingertips
if we are lucky
enough to be part
of this aspect of our world.
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: But I
think what people
miss about hedonism, what
they don't understand
is that if you're really asking,
is this really pleasurable?
What is the whole package that
comes along with my pleasures?
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: If you
start to become
aware of the
network of effects--
where things come from,
where are they leading?
What is the larger arena
within which I am enjoying?
JASON SILVA: OK.
ERIK DAVIS: Then
suddenly, things
start to shift a little
bit, because it becomes
a little harder, for
example, to truly exalt
in the god power
of your device--
JASON SILVA: When
it was made in the--
ERIK DAVIS: Right, when you
know about rare earth, you
say, oh, wait.
Those are actually the
materials that we need in order
to shrink technology.
Come with it almost as some
kind of chemical allegory,
our bound with
highly radioactive
material that is very toxic
and extremely expensive to get.
JASON SILVA: Working with fire.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
We're still in the
out chemical wager.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: It's
a kind of alliance
with forces of the earth and
forces of destruction and fire,
as well as light
and transcendence.
JASON SILVA: Uh-huh.
ERIK DAVIS: And I'm not
saying that recognizing this
means that we should pull
back, and destroy the machines,
and try to return to some
paleolithic existence.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: But I
do believe that you
have to go further and further
into the complexities as part
of the pursuit of
true enjoyment.
So for me, you start
to ask a question, what
is transcendence?
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: What does
it mean to transcend?
Is it really transcendence
to embed myself
in particular
technological frames?
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: Or perhaps
there are other ways
of moving the mind, other
ways of touching what
is essential in us that perhaps
move at a different angle
than the relentless
pursuit of the high.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: Because that
comes with entailments.
That comes with hidden packages.
It's all allies, alliances,
packs, deals, balances.
JASON SILVA: Always.
ERIK DAVIS: Always.
Well, it's so interesting
to hear you say that,
because I think there's
different flavors
of transcendence.
I think on the one
hand, there's a feeling
of ecodelic interconnection
with everything
where you basically are
extending your empathy.
Most people say,
empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight.
If it's out of sight,
it's out of mind.
So an elevation in
consciousness means
you start to be aware of more
interconnection, the more
consequences to your
everyday experience.
And so you extend your empathy.
And that's a kind
of transcendence,
and a kind of communion
with everything else.
But there's also other
kinds of transcendence.
There's just the
mediation and steering
of awareness towards states
of exultation and the sublime.
And that can just be listening
to Rachmaninoff on the piano
and being moved
to tears while you
stare into the iris of
a lover's eye, which
is something I've been trying to
do since I was in high school.
That's why I love
cinema, because it's
the last alter left.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: I get to go to
that temple of the IMAX theater,
which is the modern equivalent
of the Gothic cathedral,
it's what Alison Griffith wrote
about in the book, "Shivers
Down Your Spine," that this
is a temple and a place where
your awareness can be mediated
and pushed towards places that
tickle your soul.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: Crack for the
soul, and at the soundscape,
and that the massive screen
can push you somewhere else,
can silence the part
of the brain that's
responsible for self awareness.
You forget yourself.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: And
that transcendence
is pretty blissful too.
We're all bliss
junkies in a way.
ERIK DAVIS: Sure.
JASON SILVA: And I still think
that there's validity in that.
There's some kind of
static about that.
ERIK DAVIS: Another
way of approaching
that is just asking
this question, which
there's been a lot of
neuroscientific study
of the emotions.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: But it's
an interesting goal.
Like with any science,
you always go, why?
They're asking
certain questions,
and they're not asking
other questions.
So what do they look at?
They look at love, pair bonding,
fear, anxiety, depression.
These are the things that's
worth tons of research dollars.
Like wait?
What's happening in the brain?
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: Very,
very little work
has ever been done
on wonder and awe,
as if wonder and awe are not
absolutely fundamental parts
of our nervous systems, to
our humanness, as if they're
sort of some kind
of weird fluff they
can be ignored as we get
to the real deal, which
is these survival tactics.
And part of the reason is
because wonder and awe,
it's not so clear what their
sort of selection, viability
is.
Why do we have that?
It's not clear
exactly why that leads
to the perpetuation of the
species the way that fear,
and anxiety-- and
even depression,
they have arguments for.
JASON SILVA: There was a book.
And I did a video
about it, called,
"The Biological Advantage
of Being Awestruck," where
he says, our capacity to
awe makes us work harder
to survive because of the
bliss we get from it--
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: And that that's
why I was biologically
selected for.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: It makes
us be impregnated
with meaning because of that
feeling of being connected
with something.
It's almost like the idea that
the brain has a god hack in it.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: That the reason
that god hack was preselected
for was because it makes us
feel like we are holy beings,
and that makes us fight
harder to survive.
ERIK DAVIS: Particularly, in
terms of a group collectivity.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: Like religion
clearly exists partly
not just as an
ideological control,
a mind control kind of thing.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: It's also
a way of orchestrating
our affects, and
our experiences,
and our sense of
awe and communion
so that we collectively
begin to identify
with shared myths, shared
rituals that bring us
into resonance and allow us
to survive and to prosper
as a collectivity.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: I think one of the
problems that we have right now
is that you can just see
there's so much dissension.
There's so much violence
between religion,
and people, different
perspectives that in a way,
we're like how do we tap
into that potential for awe,
that potential for
compassionate, blissful
connection with an idea,
with people, with ritual--
but somehow, take it out of the
parochial quality and the sort
of tribal quality?
It's like we both
want, we need some
of the essence of
tribalism to return
to in the breakdown
and the dirty,
the breakdown of progress.
And yet, that tribalism
also has within it
a lot of the most
terrifying possibilities
of growth of fascism, of
a hatred, and increasing--
JASON SILVA: Right.
Because we've seen
people share in that.
They bond over their
hate over something.
ERIK DAVIS: So when I
see even the conflict now
with the Republicans
and the Democrats
and just how nasty it's
gotten, how worse--
it seems like the rules
are being broken down.
It's more feral.
It's more out of control.
That sense, which I think
is pervasive in our society,
it has that real scary
question of where
does a certain kind of
tribalism-- I believe this.
You guys are all crazy, and I
have the websites to prove it.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: Everything
feeds back on itself.
And yet, there's something
in that connection,
that bond that's very archaic
that we're working on.
JASON SILVA: So how do we
dissolve those boundaries?
McKenna used to talk about get
on an airplane flight 12 hours
and go into another
reality tunnel.
And once you get to have a
visceral experience of how
other people live, you tend to
be a little less judgmental.
You start to realize there's
not so many rights and wrongs.
It's just different.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: But
my question that I
wanted to ask you was we're
seeing a revolution now
that's connected to that
idea of dissolving boundaries
with psychedelic research.
McKenna used to say,
computers are drugs,
and drugs are computers.
They're basically
computers for inner space.
And we are seeing society
have a turnaround,
a change in the attitudes.
Marijuana is
probably going to be
made federally legal very soon.
Psilocybin studies, where
people with terminal cancer
have been given magic
mushrooms reconfiguring
their whole perception
of life and death.
Do you think that this is a
step in the right direction
for potentially
the instantiation
of a new kind of consciousess?
Like club culture-- you
go to a party in Vegas,
or a party in Miami Beach,
and that is the expression
of party, alcohol culture.
Our drugs turn it
into our environments.
Our intoxicants are then
reflected in how we hang,
and where we hang, and what
the places we hang look
like and feel like.
As more people start to
turn on, as the culture
of these entheogenic substances
becomes more accepted,
how will that change the world?
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: Not
to get all Utopian.
ERIK DAVIS: No, no.
A lot of things will
be happening at once.
I never underestimate the
capacity for human beings
to degrade the sublime.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And
you could even take
that even with looking
at party culture
and how MDMA and ecstasy,
whatever's being sold as MDMA,
and those had to have very
different expressions.
There's something very
Utopian about the rave scene,
and there are aspects
of it that are really
just an extension of that
alcohol, crass party thing.
Which is fine.
It's part of our human baggage
as well to not be judgmental,
but it also shows
that initially, MDMA
was seen as oh, this
is maybe a panacea.
This is the Utopian pill
that we need to create
bonding and connection.
JASON SILVA: 10 years of
couples' therapy in a pill.
ERIK DAVIS: And of
course, the results
are a little more fragmented.
And I think something like that
will happen with psychedelics,
as well.
On the other hand, it's an
obviously extremely positive
development-- one factor that
does seem to stay with people.
Because that's one
of the questions.
You can have awesome
experiences--
transcendent, sublime, cosmic,
all the beautiful adjectives
in the world.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: The question of
how it changes people over time
is much more murky.
It's not clear that
if there's anything
inherent in any experience to
change someone permanently,
where true transformation
comes from,
is much more of a
difficult question.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: You get a
bliss junkie, people fall
into addiction; they revert.
There's all sorts of
things that can happen.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: But one thing that
seems to be, studies show,
as a result of psychedelic use
is greater openness to novelty.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: That there
seems to be a genuine sense
that the nervous system, the
mind, whatever you want to say,
the soul gets better at
handling questions, ambiguities,
boundaries, and others.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And for me,
you mentioned the other
at the beginning of
this conversation.
For me, increasingly as I
think about these things,
as I think about spirituality,
I think about ecology,
as I think about psychedelics,
as I think about what are we
doing with all of our
devices, it really
comes into how are we
getting closer to the others.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: And by the
others, I mean the cosmos.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: I mean animals.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: I mean microbes.
ERIK DAVIS: I mean circuits.
I mean databases.
I mean this non-human,
ahuman world
that we're absolutely,
inextricably enmeshed
in that is in some sense
alive with its own--
not just in the sense that
the animals are alive,
but the whole system
has a spriteliness.
JASON SILVA: There's agency.
The matrix has meaning.
The matrix is alive.
So I want to talk to you
a little bit about that,
as well, because now, in
order to be able to witness,
to make observations
about this aliveness,
to alter our experience of the
world enough that it becomes
reenchanged that we feel
more connected to it,
that we feel more
compassionate to it.
And then we're alive
to the magic of being--
we need to be playing
with subjectivity,
which is an obsession of mine.
You've written about it.
You wrote an essay called
"Experienced Design
and the Design of Experience,"
where you describe experience
as an evanescent flux of
sensation and perception
that is, in a way, all
we have, and all we are.
And you say that new media
technologies, the culture
production of
media technologies,
needs to get better
and has to acknowledge
that what it's trying to do is
engage the technical material
of subjectivity itself.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: That our cultural
technologies are becoming more
like roller coasters than
like movies and books,
that we are hacking
the body, mind,
and being taken to new places.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: Talk to me a
little bit about subjectivity
and how we play with it.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: You use
the term "heterotopia"
to create, to describe,
the buzz that happens
at certain gatherings
and conferences when
people that share certain
values come together.
And you start to
enter this other space
with these people,
or the space when
you're talking to somebody on
a telephone across the ocean.
Where is your mind
in that moment?
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: Tell me
about heterotopia,
and playing with subjectivity,
and mediating subjectivity.
ERIK DAVIS: OK.
Well, I start talking
about heterotopia.
That's a term from Foucault.
And what he's trying
to point to is
that we have an idea of utopia,
of like some perfect place
where everything works out.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: And
he's like, maybe.
Good luck.
But hetertopia is a
place where otherness
is allowed to run riot.
JASON SILVA: Uh-huh.
ERIK DAVIS: So an easy
example with qualifications
would be something like
Burning Man, where people go.
And particularly
early on when there
were less cultural ideas of how
you were supposed to behave,
and what it was meant, and what
clothing was supposed to be,
and the furry hats.
And all of it develops its
own-- heterotopia never lasts.
It's always an evanescent point
where people come together,
and there's a kind of
open-ended question of we
don't know what social
interaction is going to be.
We don't know what
subjectivity is going to be,
how our connections are
going to happen here.
And I think there's a part
of us that really seeks that,
because we recognize in that the
possibility that things could
be done other than they are,
that the world doesn't have
to be the way it that it is.
JASON SILVA: But that's
thrilling, because then we
transcend Michael Pollan's
been there's and done
that's of the adult mind.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: The existential
boredom, or despair, or belief
that you've seen it all.
And there's nothing
else to be excited
about for a novelty
junkies, for people
who get a thrill from the
idea of something new,
of something more, that
seems to be the antidote.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: Anything that
triggers an experience
that there could be
something else is addicting.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: Right?
ERIK DAVIS: And
that's a good point.
Once it becomes addicting,
if it really is addicting,
then something
more complicated is
entered than just the sort
of generosity and richness
of such experiences, because
they become a little bit--
JASON SILVA: Because now, you
know what you want from them--
ERIK DAVIS: [INAUDIBLE],
and you got this.
So there that's
part of the trap.
That's part of the dielectric.
And for me what it
means, part of the idea
about subjectivity and
becoming more aware
of how our subjectivity
is produced
is that even as we refine
and extend our pleasures,
our enjoyment, our
capacity for intensity,
our capacity for transcendence,
for connections with others,
that there also
has to be and will
be either by ourselves
or by the people
who are producing those
experiences, an increasingly,
let's say, third person
understanding of how
those things come about.
What are the forces that are--
JASON SILVA: The anthropology
tests make the observations
from the outside.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
Or the technologist
who's tweaking the device
that you're using to get off.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: So to my mind,
expanded consciousness
is not just the exaltation,
especially the exaltation
produced from technologies.
JASON SILVA: The expertise as
to what it takes to get there.
ERIK DAVIS: Exactly.
And so it's a movement.
It's a movement where
we move into intensity.
We take everything
we can from it.
We enjoy it.
We draw from it,
and we feed it back
into a more critical
understanding
of what's leading to this.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: What's
actually behind it?
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: What
are the entailments?
What are the connections?
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: And
that's where you start
to get involved with a more
critical sense of who's
actually making money from this?
What are they
doing with my data?
And so I think that
both sides of that,
it is what it means to
become more and more intimate
with subjectivity.
JASON SILVA: So we've been
talking about subjectivity,
right?
The nature of lived experience.
Now, I'm a fan of
ecstatic states.
I'm a fan of flow states
when you feel your best,
and you perform your best.
ERIK DAVIS: It's wonderful, huh?
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
Steven Kotler and Jamie Wheal
of the Flow Genome Project
talk about advances in
technology, psychopharmacology,
neurobiology, and psychology,
the four pillars that
are allowing us to peer beneath
the hood of what's going on
in our brain during
these ethereal,
mysterious, numinous
mind states.
But I want to talk to you
about the subjective experience
of subjective
states that we love.
You once gave a talk where you
talked about dream walking.
You go through certain
urban settings,
and you're able to catalyze
a mood where you're
able to actually be
receptive to the fact
that architecture,
objects, streets,
buildings, cathedrals--
architecture talks to you.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: When you design
something, it has shape.
It has a form factor.
There's agency, and intention,
and a language to the forms
and figures that we make.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: When you walk
around Prague, or Berlin,
or Amsterdam, and
New York, if you
were in the right
receptive, subject state,
the world of objects
talks to you.
There's an animism.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: Right?
How do we turn on our
openness to that animism
versus the normal operating
baseline consciousness
which is task oriented, and I've
got to get from here to there?
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: And I'm not
stopping and staring up
at the cathedral for
15 minutes, marveling
at the forms of the concrete--
ERIK DAVIS: Sure.
JASON SILVA: --the mindedness
in the animated world.
How do you get there?
How do people get there?
ERIK DAVIS: You're asking
a really key question.
It's not easy, because the
world, the empire of work
is also everywhere we go.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: That's part
of what it means to always
be online and always be--
JASON SILVA: [INAUDIBLE] exhist.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
And in my experience,
my answers,
my practices tend to not be
particularly technologized.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: Like while I
appreciate the kinds of things
that cinema can deliver, that
virtual reality can deliver,
that games can deliver,
there's a lot of ways
in which even pharmacology,
even raves or whatever,
that my answer to your questions
are more simple and embodied.
And they really have a
lot to do with the body.
JASON SILVA: OK.
ERIK DAVIS: And not just states
of mind, but really, this body,
that there's a way of walking.
There's a way of holding.
And those are things that in
some ways, are personal to me,
that I've discovered in my
body, because of the way
it's constructed over
a long period of time.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: But I
think that there's
a way of learning the subtle
edges of consciousness, which
are almost imperceptible, unless
you're really looking for them
or have a good
structure to see what
they are, that a lot
of very ordinary states
conceal right inside of
them fabulous opportunities.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: The mind that
takes the daydreaming mind.
The mind that takes a nap.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: The mind
that spaces out,
that stops staring at
the field in front,
and opens the ears to take
in the totality of the sound.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: If you start
to develop these simple--
it's like meditation.
But it's more like
meditation on perception on--
JASON SILVA: Playing
with perception--
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah,
playing with perception,
that that can actually
provide over time.
It's like meditation like
a lot of these things.
It's not instant--
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: --a remarkably
more enchanted world.
JASON SILVA: I have to ask.
Most people, if
they want to unwind,
they'll have a glass of wine.
They'll have a
glass of champagne.
They'll have a vodka.
It does something specific to
your subjective experience.
It loosens your inhibitions.
It might make you more horny.
There is a specific use
for that intoxicant.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: The
majority of Americans
now support marijuana
legalization.
Obviously, for
medicinal purposes.
But also, like in the
Michael Pollan article
on the psychedelic
renaissance, the idea
of making well people better.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: David Lenson,
in his book on drugs,
he's a comparative
literature professor,
wrote a chapter on cannabis and
marijuana that blew my mind.
He says that
essentially, marijuana
fuses cognition and
dream and creates
a reconcilable estrangement
with the world of perception
without really distorting it.
Now, the reconcilable
estrangement, he's a first.
The world of the ordinary
becomes a little strange,
and a little extraordinary.
But then you get to
reengage with it because
of its strangeness and
novelty and reconcile
your relationship with the
world of perception and object.
So somebody might get
high and listen to a song
that they've always loved.
But all of a sudden,
they remember
why they've always loved it.
It's soul-searing
intensity pierced directly
into their brain, or why the
aesthete or the intellectual
might smoke a joint before
going to the Guggenheim Museum,
or the Amsterdam Museum
of the Moving Image.
So as America's
attitudes about cannabis
as medicinal and a recreational
substance comes online,
how do you think we
will be able to start
playing with this fusion
of cognition and dream
to make ourselves
more perceptive
to aesthetic experience?
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: Because ultimately,
that's what it's about.
You want the home
theater surround
sound external technology.
But maybe with the
legalization of cannabis,
now, you can have the
internal technology
that primes your brain to be
more open to that mediation.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
For me, the surround sound
structure is too much.
It's too invasive, and
it flattens the space
of interaction and encounter
that I find on cannabis or not
on cannabis, walking
in the woods,
before a great work of art,
listening to a symphony,
and listening to even a punk
show, or whatever, that there's
a sort of space there that our
technology, as it's getting
good at manipulating
our consciousness,
really wants to move in
there, and really trigger
fast, and really dial down, and
really get us online with it.
And some people are exalting
about that opportunity.
And I don't have a
judgment about that.
I'm glad that
there are lab rats.
I'm glad that there are post
humans who are plunging as far
forward into that as they can.
That's not my way.
JASON SILVA: OK.
ERIK DAVIS: And so
for me, when you
talk about these opportunities,
it's a little bit more
about how to bring the
edge of dream into reality.
And so the way you're talking
about how cannabis opens up
the first layers of
dream association--
both weirdness and
greater intimacy.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And I think
it's really interesting
to imagine that a lot of
people who maybe are turning
to cannabis for medical reasons,
because they've always heard
about it, now it doesn't
seem so bad-- the people who
are able to have that encounter,
maybe that they've never been
interested in the counter
culture, and drug culture,
or anything, that because of
that aesthetic sensibility
in particular, I
think that there
is a really great opportunity
for people to whatever,
join whatever-- get
out of the ruts.
JASON SILVA: Yeah, and
Leary's ubiquitous idea
of set and setting getting
fed back into the experience,
you're changing the culture
in which people can enjoy
these intoxicants responsibly.
By changing the cultural context
in which they're enjoying it,
you're changing the effect
that they're going to have,
because they're not
going to feel scared.
They're not going to
feel like deviants.
Instead, they're going
to feel like they're
having a drink, except a
slightly different effect,
and then reengage with the world
through the lens of that prism.
It could be interesting to see
how it affects consciousness.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah, absolutely.
JASON SILVA: So something else
I'd like to bring up to you.
We've talked about subjectivity.
We talked about
altering our perception
with external mediation
and technology,
with internal technology.
We've talked about our
hunger for something
more, for a hidden door
to connect to something
transcendent, to connect
something infinite
to deal with our mortal coil.
A film that resonated
with an entire generation,
I think continues to
resonate is "The Matrix."
So here, you have a film that
was a pop culture phenomenon.
But it was a profound
philosophical meditation
on the nature of reality, on
the desire for transcendence
and for escape.
And you probably
wrote, I confidently
believe, the most magnificent
piece on "The Matrix"
ever written.
It's called, "Synthetic
Meditations."
And I want to read
you a quote by you
and have you comment on
it, because when I first
saw the film, it unsettled
me and excited me,
like certain sexual
situations, but for cognition.
It just mentally made me
uncomfortable, but also
secretly really excited
about what this means.
And the scene in which Neo
takes the pill, for those who've
seen the film, and then starts
melting into the mirror,
you describe that scene
better than anybody.
So I want to read it.
So first, Morpheus
tells Neo, "No one
can be told what the matrix is.
You have to see
it for yourself."
And then Erik Davis
sums up the scene.
So like the serpent
in the Garden of Eden,
Morpheus offers Neo a pill.
Neo, of course, swallows
the molecular package,
which is really the most
heroic act in the film,
for Neo must then face
his own Cartesian passage
through madness melting
into a mirror that
alludes not only to Lewis
Carroll, "Alice in Wonderland,"
but to the mystic,
psychotic collapse
and disappearance of the
externalized ego that
stabilizes our inner void.
As Neo phases out of the matrix
he opens up, however briefly,
the fractured bardo.
That is, the secret thrill of
every fan of the false reality
genre, myself included.
The moment when baseline reality
dissolves, but no new world
has yet emerged in
its pixilating wake.
So it's when Neo starts
melting into the mirror
and he's freaking
out, it's when Dorothy
gets caught up in the
tornado and ends up in Oz.
It's when we leave our
cognitive Kansas behind.
It's the dream within a dream
sequence in "Inception."
It's Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory.
It's all of these stories,
the kiddie psychedelia
and the modern
Gnostic pop culture.
But why don't we go so
excited from being unsettled
about the nature of reality?
Isn't that supposed
to be just scary?
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: How can we like it?
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah,
that's a great question.
JASON SILVA: Thanks.
ERIK DAVIS: I asked
myself that question,
because I think like you, I
have to answer that more as much
personally as sort
of objectively.
I can talk like a historian
and say, well, the genre
develops here.
It's serving these
blah, blah, blah.
But that doesn't answer why
I get the thrill out of it,
why I have since I was a
kid, whether Philip K. Dick,
or H. P. Lovecraft, or whatever.
JASON SILVA: Right.
Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: And even
when I study religion
and I'm really
interested in agnosticism
and the history of
esoteracism, it's
often from a similar point of
if I keep following this line,
it might just start to turn
around a corner where now,
I actually can't rely entirely
on my given map of reality.
I think that's a
very healthy impulse
to question this
framework, and I
think that experiencing
it as a thrill
is a truthful reflection
of the way in which we
are forced to-- that it's always
something that happens to us.
It's not just an idea.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: It's not
just like oh, there's
another world behind this world.
It's an experience of
loss, which in a sense,
is a little premonition
of the big loss.
JASON SILVA: Leaving
the every day.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
And it's a kind of death.
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: That's
the point is that Neo
has to die not
only to the world,
but to the person he thought
he was, to the relationships
that's sustain him, the
identity that sustains him,
the job that he has.
All of that, which
is a kind of death.
JASON SILVA: Yep.
ERIK DAVIS: And so the idea
that there is something more
is pleasurable.
But also, the sense that
there's something in us that
can navigate such transitions.
JASON SILVA: Something survives.
There is a witness that
can move through worlds.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
And dance with it,
and even move it.
And I think part of this,
also, the secret encoded
in the matrix is precisely
that this is also
a film in which the
special effects that
were most novel in that film,
which then of course, become
ordinary in
subsequent iterations,
has so much to do with
a ballet of movement,
the manipulation of time,
moving through different speeds
and slowness.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: All of those,
to me, were an indication
of the way in which
the films were encoding
not just the false
reality genre, but also,
a kind of almost a sort
of shamanic encouragement
that you actually
have the capacity
to navigate this
degree of uncertainty,
this degree of not
knowing what's a fiction
and what's a fact.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: And that's of
course, one of the main things
that we face, that we're
already in this world
and that is going to
become more intense
is that division between
fiction and fact,
that the hard reality
of where our bodies die,
and the water tables
are collapsing,
and people are manipulating
the economic system
for a really untoward gains.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: That's going
along at the same time
at which there's this
profusion of fictions.
In fact, it's really
hard to get at reality.
If I'm like, gee, what happened
with the Boston bombing?
It was weird.
I want to find out what
really happened that day.
JASON SILVA: Then people fall
into conspiracy theories--
ERIK DAVIS: Where
am I going to go in?
Which conspiracy theory?
And then they're all
conspiracy theories,
and then it's all
loose all of a sudden.
JASON SILVA: Sure.
ERIK DAVIS: And I'm in
my own private Idaho's
flying blind, trying
to communicate,
trying to coordinate some
consensus sense of reality.
JASON SILVA: And then you get
into the Roswell stuff, UFOs,
this and that.
ERIK DAVIS: And I'm
saying that not to say,
oh, we should be
conspiracy theorists,
or oh, we shouldn't be
because I wouldn't say
that either, by any means.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: But it's more
that dance with fictions which
is, in a way, the dance of the
matrix is part of our existence
now.
It's part of our politics.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
ERIK DAVIS: It's part
of our self identity.
JASON SILVA:
Everything is theater.
ERIK DAVIS: It's part
of what we're doing.
JASON SILVA:
Everything is theater.
ERIK DAVIS:
And there's some
scaries to that.
There's some nihilism to that.
There's a deep alienation
implied in that.
And at the same time, there is
an invitation to a better play,
or a better kind of performance.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
Well, even just
cognitively, intellectually,
and aesthetically,
for me I think,
it provides a safe
place in which
I can go to dangerous places
and ask dangerous questions
with my mind.
I think that Neo
taking the pill,
and then me wondering
what's it going to do.
And then he turns
right, and his arms
starts to melt--
the freaky, almost
schizophrenic disjointing
of everyday reality
is the cognitive
equivalent of when
you're going up on
the roller coaster
before it's about to flip over
the top and drop insanely.
You can't really even see the
bottom, because it's going up.
And that feeling you
get in your stomach--
the cognitive, intellectual
equivalent of that is now that.
Or the dream within
the dream scenes
in "Inception,"
where he explains
that when he and his
wife went into the limo,
the fourth layer,
then they decided
to hide their little artifact.
And then she forgot
that she was in a dream
so that after living a whole
life there and him saying,
this was all in a
limbo, let's wake up.
Then she brought the
belief that that dream
wasn't real into their
real waking state.
And that's like a person
having a psychotic breakdown
as a person that
can become convinced
that this reality is not real.
ERIK DAVIS: Mm-hmm.
JASON SILVA: Because if you're
fully convinced, that's it.
You're not tied into
the consensus trench.
You're either in your
own personal heaven
or your own personal hell.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: And I
think that flirting
with that in these kinds of
films gets certain people off.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: "Eternal Sunshine
of the Spotless Mind,"
another example.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
And that's also very old.
If you go back in the history
of religion, particularly
in India, there's very
ancient tales of dreams,
within dreams, within dreams,
of people living entire lives,
and then realizing that it was
all just a fantasy, a drama.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: So that idea
is very fundamentally
a part of human consciousness.
And I think it has to do
with our experience of dream
in a sense that this is not
a cultural construction.
This is something
all human beings
dream and all human beings
have been dreaming for tens,
if not hundreds of
thousands of years.
And one of the
conclusions from dream
is that I can be very
much in a real world,
and then not anymore.
And that gap is
a gap of freedom.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: But in
a way, we can only
get into that gap of freedom by
also risking either psychosis
or death.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And that
that's part of the thrill,
because we're just
getting a little flavor.
A movie, it's safe.
I'm in a cushy seat.
I've got popcorn.
JASON SILVA: Right.
ERIK DAVIS: And yet, there
is a cognitive memory
and anticipation of
other kinds of gaps
that maybe are much more--
JASON SILVA: Glitches
in the matrix.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
And that's partly then how
we navigate a culture that
is changing so fast, that is so
full of fabricated realities,
and that is so full
of glitches and noise.
That's why for me, it's
always really important
to pay attention to as
well as using a technology
to get what you want, or
to enjoy what you're going
to enjoy, and even
recognizing how
it is a kind of congealed
dream of a possibility
that at the same time
it's also a pain the ass.
It brings along things
that I didn't intend.
It doesn't work
the way I want to.
And if I look into
the conditions
under which it was made
and how it's being sold,
and how it's entering
into people's lives.
Then I see all sorts of
glitches, all sorts of cracks,
all sorts of little
abysses that open up.
JASON SILVA: Mm-hmm.
ERIK DAVIS: And for
me, we're in a process
now where both of those
minds have to be operatives.
So I think that there's
something very powerful,
as well as juicy about
these gaps, these glitches,
these cracks, because that
is where our critique lies.
That is where our willingness
to not buy the comforting dream
lies.
And so we learn
to play with that.
JASON SILVA: And self correct.
Well, it reminds me a little
bit of that Danny Boyle
film, "The Beach," when
they find that island
and then they go
to this paradise.
And then the whole
idea is nobody
wants to bust up the party.
So when one of the characters
gets sick or one of them
gets bitten by a shark, they
just put him in the woods
and throw him away so it's
out of sight, out of mind,
because nobody
wants a buzz kill.
ERIK DAVIS: Right.
JASON SILVA: Nobody wants
the high to go away.
ERIK DAVIS: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: And I
think what you're saying
and you're saying so well
is that even as these tools
and technologies, the myth,
magic, and mysticism that's
giving us so many
wonderful experiences,
that we should still be mindful
of what it took to get there
and what are the consequences
that it's causing so that we
can remedy, self correct,
adjust, upgrade, and make sure
that we are living
to our potential
as people that
believe in justice
and that sense of right.
ERIK DAVIS: Absolutely.
JASON SILVA: And that
we're not just bliss
junkies at the expense
of, but rather,
that we can bring
everybody into this waking
dream, as we author it.
ERIK DAVIS: Excellent.
Well said.
JASON SILVA: Dude, this has
been an absolute treat, just
a cognitive thrill.
You've taken me on the best
kind of roller coaster,
"Alice in Wonderland."
I've transcended my cognitive
Kansas and everything I liked.
So thank you for
what you've produced.
Thank you for existing.
Thank you for "TechGnosis,"
which has been reprinted.
And I think everybody should
read as part of their journey.
ERIK DAVIS: People
still like it.
It was written a while ago.
And yet, it still resonates.
It clearly inspires in some
way that I'm not entirely
in control of.
JASON SILVA: It comes through
you, but not from you,
and though it is with you,
it belongs not to you.
ERIK DAVIS: Excellent.
Well put, well put.
JASON SILVA: But whatever
it is you've channeled into,
I just really want to thank you.
This is the kind of book
that I like to take with me
and I like to open to any page.
And I like to read something
fascinating that usually
triggers a shot of awe episode
and all kinds of cognitive
thrills.
So make sure you
pick up "TechGnosis."
Make sure you follow
Erik Davis on Twitter.
He's @erik_davis, Erik with the
"k" at the end, @erik_davis.
Get "TechGnosis" today.
And your podcast-- why
don't you tell everybody
about your podcast?
ERIK DAVIS: Well, it's
called "Expanding Mind,"
and it's on the
progressive radio network.
And it's been going
for about five years.
And we cover consciousness,
neuroscientist, spirituality,
technology-- just zones that
are covered in this book.
It's a weekly chat, very similar
to this-- informal but heady.
JASON SILVA: Yes.
ERIK DAVIS: And I have a
wonderful cohost, Maja D'Aoust,
the white witch of LA.
JASON SILVA: I love that.
ERIK DAVIS: So got to
give a shout out to Maja.
And we have a lot of fun.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
So check out expanding minds.
And thanks for watching
"Shots of Awe,"
creative session
and conversation
with the dazzling Erik Davis.
ERIK DAVIS: I love it man.
Your enthusiasm is great.
JASON SILVA: Thanks man.
It's all real bro.
I can't help it.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It could be.
But for me, the
best part of a trip
is always waking
up in the morning.
Coming down is the good part.
It should be anyway.
Coming down is the part
where you're like, OK.
JASON SILVA: What
have I learned?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
What did I learn, and
how do I apply this?
And what is this?
And then you go
out in the woods,
and you smell reality
again from that new place.
And you realize, oh my god.
I'm only 1% of what I could be.